What are you doing?
*Marzia laughing*
Stop..
Okay, so Marzia doesn't know which game we're playing today
Uh wait don't turn!!!
don't turn!
Go back go back!
It's Valentine's day
We are playing... Genital Jousting!!
*dramatic music starts playing*
*Marzia* Oh no.. *Felix* Oh yeah!
Is this the one you have to go and.. put it in the back?
Hey!!
Butt sex.
With a cacti..
What the hell?
Okay.. Oh no!!!!! *Felix*
Ewww!!!! *Felix*
Don't go near me Marzia, don't go near me.
*Felix* Don't.. *Marzia* Oh no, ooooo.
*Felix* No! Don't go in my butt, Marzia.
*Marzia* Isn't that what.. OOOOOOOOHHH!!
*Felix* How dare you?
*Felix* Disgusting.
*Felix* Wrestling, okay fine. *marzia* I don't know if I'm ready for this..
*Spanish music* *Marzia* You too cute in a way but-- *Felix* Hey we're all in a boat, Marzia this-- *Felix winces* Oh my god, what is that?
*Felix* Watch out, I'll protect you Marzia.
*Felix* I'll protect you.
*Marzia* You lost a hat man!
*Felix* Heh, no I'm the black one. *Marzia* Yeah, but the other one.
*Felix and Marzia* "Ohhh! *Felix* Oh god, I'm-- yeahhhh!! Marzia!! *both laugh*
*Felix* I went out, *both laugh*
*Felix* This is the worst game, this is so awkward. Oh my god.
*Felix* Okay we're going to race, we're gonna race, we're going to race, Marzia.
*Marzia* Oooooh.. *Felix* Ah! Got em
*Felix* Oh shit, its-
*Felix* AHHHH!! Don't put-- *Marzia laughs hysterically*
*Felix* Uh, you're out, yeah!!!
Ooooh, swimming penis.
*Felix reads* Double delight.
*Felix* Oh my god,
*Marzia* Am I supposed to put it in-- yeah boy!
*Felix* Uh let me get on this, no nonununuh
*Felix* Let me get in-- yeah!!!
*both laugh*
*Felix* This game is disgusting.
*Felix* Its foul.
*Felix*  its another race!
*Felix Don't go in my butt this time, please.
*Felix* No Marzia, please, please, minasha please! *lady* I'm Minasha please.
*Felix* No!!! stop-- noooo, eh- eh- eh- no! no!
*Felix* Eh! Na- eh- *Marzia makes a strange bird screech*
*eagle makes same sound Marzia made*
*Marzia* How do you get out? *Felix* Jiggle! I don't know.
*Marzia* I did it! *Felix* NOOOOOO!!!!!!!!
*Marzia* Bye!!
*Felix* Dammit, stupid cock, get outta here, how did you win?
*happy music*
*Felix* Dance dance
*Felix* okay okay okay this is double delight, double delight
*Felix* Careful, caref- Marzia!
*Marzia laughs again*
*Felix* You're greedy. Whoever came up with this game is a fricking genius.
*Felix* Wrestling, are we going to wrestle?
*Marzia* yeah.
*Felix* Yep. *Marzia* How?
*Felix* Don't worry about the details.
*Felix* Oh its wrestling time- oh nop- nuuuuuu
eh Marzia--
*Felix* eh eh eh *Marzia* nooo!
*Felix* ehehehehe *Marzia* No!
*Felix* Yeaaaahhhh!
*Felix* Yeah you were a albino, albino dick
*Felix* Wrestling on a boat, okay.
*Felix* This is the best party game, I swear to God.
*Felix* Look at the bird penis!
*Felix* There's a bird penis!!
*Felix* May the best penis win.
*Felix* Eh- no, no, no.
*Felix* Why are they-- eh how-
*Felix* Hooo- heh- Nooooooo!
*Song* I bid you all,
*song* A very fond,
*song* farewell.....
*Felix* You can get longer from doing it. *Marzia* The fork is in the way!
*Felix* Oh just luuuu--
*Marzia* Oh you're so long!!
*Felix* I am sooo long Marzia, tell them how long I am.
*Marzia* I am going so fast,
*Felix* How are you so fast,
*Felix* What are you, a sand ssss-
*Felix* ssss sand penis? *Marzia* Let me go.
*Felix* That's a good one.
*Felix* How are you winning this one?
*Marzia* You're doing so good.
*Felix* I'm coming for your ass, though.
*Felix* Oh!
*Felix* Oh!!
*Felix* Aughhhhhhh!
*Felix* No, No.
*Felix* No!
*Felix* Noooooooooo!
*Felix* That's not fair.
*Felix* Okay, alright.
*Felix* No--
*Felix* Stay away, stay away.
*Felix* What did I say?
*Felix* What did I say, Marzia?
*Felix* Stop, get away from me.
*Felix* You're disgusting.
*Felix* Okay, so fine, you won this one.
*Felix* Let's finish this off with a party mode
*Felix* and whoever wins the party mode
*Felix* gets to officially be called the greatest penis.
*Marzia* It would be a great thing if I had a penis.
*Felix* Okay, Marzia. *Marzia laughs*
*Felix* Then wrestle me, huh?
*Felix* Why don't you wrestle me?
*spanish music plays* *Felix* Show me what you got
*Marzia* Ohhohohoh!! *Felix* WHAAAAT???
*Felix* Double delight
Okay I gotta get good points here.
*both laugh*
*Felix* eyhehehehyyyy!
*Felix* Okay last one, cactus run.
*Felix* Okay, here we go.
*Felix* Oh my god.
*Felix* Ohoho nooooooo!
*Felix* Ohhh no,
*Felix* Oh!
*Felix* Nooooooo!
*Felix, very irritated* NOooooO!!!
*Felix* Marzia, you promised--
You promised I would be the best penis..
*Felix* Stupid!
*Marzia* I'm sorry!
*Felix* Why don't you play your stupid game alone?
*Marzia* Oh I will.
*spanish music plays*
*Felix* Happy Valentines Day
If you don't have anyone to celebrate with,
*Marzia* You can play this game.
*Felix* I guess you can play this game
Actually you need to play with two people
*Marzia laughs*
*Felix* If you have two controllers
*Felix* you can kind of play with yourself.
That would be great, I would recommend doing that.
*Felix* But anyway, leave a like if you enjoyed
And as always,
*Felix* Have bro-- *Marzia laughs*